in the South Carolina primary on the
other side of the country the Republican
governor is trying to hold off a
hard-charging businessman who was a
complete unknown in the state six months
ago and he's getting some help
correspondent Jonathan Serrie looks at
that race tonight from Columbia South
Carolina governor Henry McMaster cast
his ballot this morning in Columbia
while challenger John Warren voted in
Greenville both candidates in South
Carolina's GOP runoff for governor call
themselves Trump conservatives but it
was McMaster the president came to stump
for right from day one when I came down
here Henry McMaster I said sir why are
you with me he said because I like what
you're saying returning a favor to one
of his earliest supporters mr. Trump
rallied a packed room at a McMaster
event many in the manga hat wearing
crowd were there to see the president
more than the candidate and Warren hopes
many of them will vote for him Donald
Trump has a ton of support in South
Carolina a lot of my supporters are his
supporters this is not a referendum on
President Trump this is referendum on
Henry McMasters failed leadership and my
vision of conservative reform throughout
our state Warren a Greenville
businessman in combat vet is touting his
status as a political newcomer promising
to drain the swamp in the state capital
coming from South Carolina's socially
conservative Upstate region may help
Warren in a primary race in which
abortion is played front and center but
McMaster who rose to the governorship
after nikki Haley joined the Trump
administration as UN Ambassador has been
touting the businesses and jobs that
have moved into his state during his
brief tenure as governor we got a great
team he goes from the White House to the
Statehouse to your house and the people
in South Carolina know that we're on the
way up things are getting better and we
want to keep this team together
the winner of tonight's GOP primary
runoff will face Democrat James Smith in
the November general election Smith
who's both lawyer and a state
representative hopes that his experience
as a combat vet will have broad appeal
in this strongly Pro military state the
polls close in about half an hour Brett
watch that all the results here on Fox
Jonathan thank you